ja wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung
dieses seminares über philosophische
emotions theorien heute geht es um zwei
ganz große philosophen die nicht gerade
leicht sind die aber was wirklich
wichtiges zu sagen hatten und sagen
haben über nichts geringeres als die
angst und sind das höhere und kicker und
martin halliger kirche hatten wir schon
letzten sitzung ist gleich noch was dazu
jetzt noch kurz zum plan des seminars
dass sie immer sehen wo wir gerade sind
der letzten sitzung hatten wir die
verzweiflung beikircher ich komme darauf
gleich noch zu sprechen
nach oben rechts ins leben zu letzten
zeit zu sein
jetzt geht es heute um die angst bei
chilliger und heiliger der nächsten
sitzung werden wir uns mit neid und
eifersucht befassen
da geht es dann auch so ein bisschen ins
unmoralische momentan halten wir uns ja
noch ziemlich neutral moralisch gesehen
auf angst ist moralisch indifferent
genauso verzweiflung wieder gut also
wieder verwerflich moralisch noch
besonders lobenswert beim neid oder
eifersucht sieht schon anders aus da
kommen wir den moralischen bereich sein
was die sache noch zusätzlich spannend
macht dann nehme den hass auch noch mit
moralisch problematische emotionen dann
möchte ich gerne zu behandeln
und am ende haben uns natürlich das
beste verschluss auf die liebe und gehen
ein bisschen die artikel augustinus aber
auch die innere neue zeit an die ich
darüber promoviert hat und wir gehen
auch für frankfurt kann man noch zu
sprechen den ich auch sehr schätze der
auch nicht uninteressante nicht gerade
interessantes sehr zentrales zum
phänomen oder zur emotion der liebe
gesagt hat so jetzt aber nochmal kurzen
rückblick zu diesem hier
denn sie alle kennen das ist für kicker
und er hat eine schrift verfasst titel
die krankheit zum tode das ist natürlich
die verzweiflung die krankheit zu tode
und jetzt gebe ich eine kurze
zusammenfassung der letzten sitzung die
verzweiflung ist nach senegal kurz
gesagt ein missverhältnis selbst das
selbst ist nach kwg gesehen hat was ganz
ganz komplexe daraus folgt dass die
verzweiflung eine problematische art von
einstellung ist nicht nur aber auch dass
zeit wieder sie hatten eine gewisse
kognitive dimension was sie auch
emotionen auszeichnet unterscheidet
jetzt drei formen von verzweiflung
einmal die verzweiflung dass man sich
nicht bewusst ist dann selbst zu haben
das ist nach riga aber die uhren
eigentliche vergreifen
dann ahnt dass man verzweifelt ich nicht
man selbst sein will
das ist schon zentrale und am ende die
zentralste form eigentlich so form der
verzweiflung dass man verzweifeln selbst
sein würde
das ist sind diese drei formen der
verzweifeln
und jetzt kann man nach kicker der die
verzweifelt biologischen kontext
betrachtet nur dadurch 7 hat aus ihren
kommen gesagten es ist eine einstellung
wenn man ganz bewusst sich in seinen
verschiedenen relationen vor allem
derjenigen zu dem eigenen grund und der
das nach türkischer gott bewusst wird
erst dann kann man der verzweifelt gegen
und man darf sich da nicht täuschen oder
verstricken in diesen sehr komplexen
relation die die verzweiflung ausmacht
dann könnte man die verzweifelt auch
durchaus mit bezug auf kirche aber auch
allgemein als eine form von rastlose
unkoordinierte angst bezeichnen
warum die angst ist ein bisschen
koordinierter und da ist natürlich nicht
befand muss sie von der furcht
unterscheiden wie wir das heute tun
werden aber ich denke es sein dass die
ausweglosigkeit die verzweiflung
charakterisiert
verbunden unter anderem auch mit einer
angst und das führt uns jetzt zur
heutigen sitzung in der es nämlich dann
auch um die angst gehen sollte zuvor
aber noch mal kurz zur verzweiflung
zurück zur kirche kann nämlich wie das
selbst aufgebaut ist sie haben sich
erinnern dass selbst ist nach ewiger
geist und der geist begriff wird wenn es
um die angst bei kirche geht auch eine
rolle spielt also haben diese synthese
gegensätze unendlichkeit endlichkeit
ewigkeit zeitlichkeit freiheit und
notwendigkeit das sind so diese regatta
diese pole könnte man auch sagen
und dazu gibt's ein verhältnis das ist
noch nicht das selbst sondern das selbst
ist dass sie dass das verhältnis dass
ich zu sich selbst erhält und das
verhältnis verhält sich wiederum zu
etwas anderen dass es dann der grund und
die verzweiflung resultiert aus einem
missverhältnis dieser sehr komplexen
konstellation ziemlich formal gesehen
soviel zur letzten sitzung und jetzt
geht es zu der heutigen sitzung zu den
leitfragen also büchern handelt es sich
bei der angst um meine emotionen das ist
die frage zu stellen wie schon besitzt
die angst eine gefühls urteilt und
motivation struktur worauf bezieht sich
die angst das haben wir vielleicht auch
ein bisschen vernachlässigt bisher alles
intentionalen objekt die scham kann man
schlecht sagen worauf sich die scham
bezieht aber ein selbst aber die angst
wollen wir uns fragen worauf bezieht
sich dann worin unterscheiden sich die
theorie die angst nein kirche heiliger
und wie verhält sich die emotionen der
angst zu der bisher behandelten
emotionen der dass die letzte fragen die
wir uns auch stellen wollen
so und jetzt komme ich gleich zu
sprechen auf folgendes man muss wieder
dazu sagen dass die angst da im rahmen
einer theologischen betrachtung oder die
haben theologischen philosophie
behandelt wird unschuld ist unwissenheit
in der unschuld ist der mensch nicht als
geist bestimmt sondern seelisch bestimmt
in unmittelbarer einheit mit seiner
natürlichkeit der geist ist träumen den
menschen diese auffassung stimmt ganz
mit derjenigen der bibel wahlen die der
menschen in der unschuld die kenntnis
des unterschieds zwischen gut und böse
abspricht da ist das buch genesis der
sündenfall also darauf bezieht dass ich
jetzt hier müssen wir noch mal den
begriff des geistes uns vergegenwärtigen
vierter begriff des geistes der
verteidiger immer eine ziemlich große
rolle spielt denkt sie zurück dass
selbst ist geist dass selbst das geist
und verhältnis zu sich selbst und das
angebot das spielt auch hier eine rolle
ok so weiter geht es in diesem zustand
ist friede und ruhe habe es ist
zur gleichen zeit etwas anderes sei das
nicht gut frisiert streit ist denn es
ist ja nichts da womit sich streiten
ließe was ist es dann nicht welche
wirkung aber hat nichts
es gibt angst das ist das tiefe
geheimnisse und schuld dass sie zu
gleicher zeit angsträumen projektierte
geist seine eigene wirklichkeit diese
wirklichkeit aber ist nichts
dieses nichts aber zieht die unschuld
ständig außer ihr jetzt haben wir hier
diesen ganz zentralen begriff des nichts
als die angst ist auf dass nichts
gerichtet das ist schon ein bisschen
zählt aber das hängt ganz wenig zusammen
daran wird dann auch wie wir heute noch
sehen werden heiliger anknüpfen an
dieses nichts im verhältnis zu angst
ok angst ist etwas träumen das hat mit
den träumen geist zu tun die etwas
projektiert also etwas fantasie die
angst ist eine bestimmung des träumen
geistes und gehört als solche in die
psychologie im wachen ist der
unterschied zwischen mir selbst meinem
anderen gesetzt im schlafen ist der
suspendierten träumen ist er ein
angedeutetes nicht die wirklichkeit des
geistes zeigt sich ständig als eine
gestalt von der seine möglichkeit
gelockt wird die aber verschwunden ist
so wie ihr nachher greift und ein nichts
ist das nur ängste kann mehr kann sie
nicht so lange sind sich lediglich zeigt
okay jetzt geht um die wirklichkeit des
geistes und die möglichkeit also es geht
um letztendlich auch um gefeiert es geht
um die möglichkeiten die der geist
begreifen kann und das ist ja egal jetzt
sagt der grund der axt wir müssen uns
auf die vielen zugriffe niederrhein ging
weiter sagte der mit dem begriff angst
nennt man fast nie der psychologie bernd
ich muss deshalb darauf aufmerksam
machen dass er von furcht und ähnlichen
begriffen begann sind ja verschieden ist
dass sie sich auf etwas bestimmtes
beziehen während die angst die
wirklichkeit der freiheit als
möglichkeit für die möglichkeit ist man
sind daher bei einem tier keine angst
vor ihm weil ist
seiner natürlichkeit nicht als geist
stimmt also nochmal zusammengefasst
nur wenn wir einen geist haben oder
etwas geist ist kann es überhaupt angst
empfinden und tiere sind nicht als
geister bestimmt dass diese strukturen
bestimmt also können sie keine angst
haben oder empfinden und jetzt müssen
wir uns genau überlegen was jetzt hier
das objekt der angst ist anders als die
furcht die sich auf etwas bestimmtes
bezieht
ja ich fürchte mich vor denken sie an
das wort vorbei es gibt eine eröffnung
von bbi das ist ein spinnenangst angst
vor spinnen dass die furcht und chiquita
kids jetzt von der furcht die angst ab
und die angst die gilt nichts konkreten
keinen gegenstand sonst spielen sollen
sie gilt der möglichkeit die möglichkeit
die uns sind etwas
bedeuten kann die ungewiss dass die
möglichkeit ist jetzt als gegenstand der
angst natürlich so verschieden
unterscheiden von einem bestimmten
gegenstand wie einer spinne es ist viel
offener für unbestimmt hat also die
angst ist die wirklichkeit der freiheit
als möglichkeit für die möglichkeit das
müssen wir jetzt mal dabei stehen lassen
es geht also um die möglichkeiten ist
unbestimmt
das ist das objekt die angst kurz gesagt
ok weiter wenn wir die dialektischen
bestimmung der angst betracht so zeigt
sich dass sie gerade die psychologischen
230 kite haben angst ist sympathisch
antipathie und anti pathetisches
sympathie man sich leicht denke ich dass
das in einem ganz anderen sinne eine
psychologische bestimmung ist als jene
von coupies kendzia die begehrlichkeit
der sprache auch bestätigt ist voll und
ganz man sagt die süße angst die süße
beängstigend
man sagt eine seltsame angst keine scheu
angst und so weiter interessant finde
ich jetzt hier das was ich jetzt gleich
markiere nämlich die sympathische
antipathie und die anti pathetische
sympathie als sie sehen hier das ist
entgegengesetzt also sympathie
antipathie heißt wirklich eine eine
gewisse distanz analyse abgrenzung ein
zurückschrecken das aber eben
zurückschrecken irgendwie doch noch
interessiert ist fasziniert ist
und genauso eine sympathie als eine hin
beziehungen hinwendung die aber in der
hinwendung zugleich abgestoßen ist das
ist diese zweideutigkeit also die angst
ist nichts eindeutig ist und das führt
mich eben da war zu generellen
betrachtung die ich eben schon mal
gesagt hatte dass mir emotionen solche
spannungen zur spannungsvollen zustände
zurlauben schein während gefühle und
stimmungen und auch effekte ihr
eindeutig so können emotionen
vieldeutig und auch in sich gespannt
sein kurz gesagt emotionen sind viel
komplexer als es eben effekte stimmungen
und große gefühle sind und das zeigt wie
ich finde es sehr schön hier die angst
die ebenso paradox er würde sagen die
rag tisch also in widersprüchen
operieren bestimmt
je weniger geist desto weniger angst
ebenso wie also das verhältnis der angst
ihrem gegenstand zu etwas das nichts ist
der sprach genug sagt jedenfalls bekannt
sich ängstigen gesang nicht ganz und gar
zweideutig ist so wird der übergang von
der unschuld zur schulter hier
verwirklicht werden kann
gerade so dialektisch sein dass er die
erklärung als talseitige er weiß was die
sein soll nämlich als psychologischen
wir müssen jetzt nicht genauer fragen
was er jetzt technologie versteht uns
geht es einfach darum wir jetzt die
angst charakterisiert und hier möchte
ich betonen das spiel und das nichts das
nichts das irgendwie in der möglichkeit
zusammen mit der möglichkeit der
freiheit dieser zweideutigkeit die
antipathie tische sympathie die
sympathische antipathie und das mit ihr
dialektisch sie kennen alle aus der
schule noch die elektrische erörterung
pro und contra weil sie mit
widersprüchen operieren und mit
widersprechen umgehen das ist hier nach
kicker ein charakteristikum der angst
ein zitat der mensch ist eine synthese
des seelischen und leiblich eine
synthese aber ist undenkbar
die beiden bestandteile sich nicht etwas
dritten verein dieses dritte ist der
geist der unschuld ist der mensch nicht
nur tiere wie er denn überhaupt wenn er
im augenblick seines liebsten team werde
niemals menschenwürde der geist ist also
vorhanden aber als unmittelbare als
träumen der geist und sofern vorhanden
ist ist in gewissem sinne eine
feindliche macht denn er stört denn in
das feld ist zwischen musik und bleibt
das zwar bestand hat aber dennoch
insofern nicht bestand hat als ihn erst
durch den geist erhält andererseits ist
er eine freundliche macht das verhältnis
der gerade konstituieren weges
verhältnis hat der mensch stimmt zu
dieser zweite gemacht wie verhält sich
denke alles zu sich selbst und zu seiner
bedingung er verhält sich als angst
also hin der geist ist dasjenige am
menschen was seine möglichkeit betrifft
seine handlungsoptionen die aber eben
nicht so wie vorhandene gegenstände zu
denken sind sondern die
handlungsoptionen in der freiheit müssen
die uns immer selbst schaffen wahl oder
freiheit bedeutet ja nicht jetzt
unbedingt zwischen zu wählen zwischen
schokoladen als und nanni lies das wäre
jetzt eine schlechte zu simple
auffassung von freizeit freiheit
bedeutet und selbst ziele setzen
entfernten die wir dann auch verfolgen
und das bedeutet dass wir diese ziele
ins nichts entwerfen ein
möglichkeitsraum in den vieles möglich
aber noch nicht möglich ist und diese
freiheit zu realisieren in diesem nichts
etwas zu verwirklichen das ist eben
gerade das was uns angst macht so so
viel zügiger und jetzt kommen wir zu
seinem nachfolger in gewisse mit
gewissem recht nämlich zu diesem netten
herrn zu jahren ist es ist dass martin
haidinger und er hat ein wolf als eine
schrift mit dem titel sein und zeit
das kennt sie alle schon mal gehört
jeden fall von 127 das ist es ein
hauptfeld ist ein bisschen was zu ihm
also heiliger nur ganz kurz sie wissen
es bestimmt auch schon besser als er war
ein deutscher philosoph und
phänomenologie ich erwähne deswegen
nochmals phänologie weil wir diese
seminare schon einen antrag von analogen
behandelt hatten nämlich niemand
geringeren als max scheler ich nach oben
rechts wieder der den zu dieser sitzung
hinein
auch der bart zeitgleich unabhängig von
martin heidegger auch ein phänomenologie
die frage ist ja immer wer ist jetzt
interessanter heiliger oder schwerer da
gibt es verschiedene lager denke jeder
hat seine eigene berechtigung sein
hauptwerk seinen zeit in diesem
hauptwerk entwickelt heide eine
sogenannte fundamental und rookie es
geht um alles um das sein
das sind unternehmen und zwar nicht um
irgendwie ein bestimmtes sein dass
sondern und jetzt ganz ähnlich wie bei
chilliger dass selbst ein verhältnis das
was sie zu sich selbst fern so geht es
weniger um das dasein und zwar das
dasein
ich schreibe meine dass das eine
das dasein das ist auch etwas themas in
seinem sein um sein sein selbst geht
darum geht es ihm
und dieses dasein dass das
ausgezeichnete sein darum darüber
erschließt sich die welt ihre
wirklichkeit in ihre untere die wir
müssen von casa hinausgehen und da sie
jetzt endlich die unter logi
exemplifiziert und ich haben
irgendwelche gegenstände die in der welt
finden müssen immer auf uns selbst
beziehen unsere existenz kurz gesagt
deswegen beteilige häufig auch ein
existenz wieder so an betrachtet sondern
dieses werk hat unter anderem einfluss
auf die theologie rudolf bultmann ist
jetzt in den ideen hamburger schule
das ist also sehr einflussreich lesen
und jetzt möchte ich noch auf eine
jüngste 2014 immer mehr 2014 immer mehr
in die kommende tendenz etwas sagen
nämlich die posthume veröffentlichung
der sogenannten schwarzen hälfte in
denen sich auch sehr politisch
unkorrekte dinge teilweise auch sehr
problematisch antisemitische tendenzen
finden
seit dieser veröffentlichung dieser
sogenannten schwarzen hefte wird seine
philosophie immer mehr kritisch
beurteilen
die frage ist einfach die jetzt seine
heutige hat er auch im
nationalsozialismus eine rolle gespielt
eine gremien so pathetisch beteiligt
wenn es einfach die frage wie verhält
sich die schwarzen hälfte zu seinem werk
sein und zeitlich ist ja noch viel
früher erschien es gibt verschiedene
forschungs meinung manche sagen
diese schrift seine zeit da finden wir
schon hier so anklänge so
nationalistische anhänge total etat
risse an hängen manche sagen nein das
ist davon ganz unterschieden ich möchte
ich sage ja auch gar nicht weiter
diskutieren möchten wir darauf hinweisen
dass heidegger nächster zeit so ein
bisschen mehr problematisiert wird wegen
dieser schwarzen heftigen
okay das sollten sie jetzt aber heute
nicht weiter betreffen heute geht es um
die angst die wie ich glaube völlig frei
von problematischen tendenzen ist diese
analyse wir können es aber natürlich
auch darauf hin
dann spielte noch diskutieren ich soll
jetzt möchte ich hier so partie tat auch
noch bringt zunächst mal ist heiliger
sehr ehrlich das hat nämlich am
weitesten ist der kicker vor betrunkene
analyse des angst phänomens und zwar
wiederum im theologischen zusammenhang
einer psychologischen exposition des
problems der erbsen also gesteht könig
und zu dass er natürlich der angst somit
das bisher interessanteste gesagt habe
aber jetzt kommt natürlich heiliger der
noch viel interessanteres dazu zu sagen
hat und zwar findet sich die analyse der
angst in paragraf 40 von seiner zeit und
sie wird als eine grund befindlichkeit
charakterisiert eine grund
befindlichkeit des daseins das dasein
können sie sich ungefähr so vorstellen
wie den geist bei kicker es geht darum
dass das dasein ganz verschiedene
relation entsteht ist es nicht von der
welt getrennt zu denken wie jetzt zum
beispiel so eine risiko geht ans breite
card dagegen wendet sich heute kassen
kritisch sondern es geht ihm darum dass
das dasein in verhältnissen steht er
spricht von dem in der welt sein mit
vielen bindestrichen all das dasein ist
immer schon im kontext fordert ist
existiert nicht unabhängig niesen
substanz begriff beide grad nahe gelegt
hat in der angst da findet sich das
dasein auf eine besondere weise in der
welt und zwar so dass es sich dabei als
erschlossen er fehlt es weh sondern
eines einst möglichkeit ist da sein
freundlichen aufschluss geben über es
selbst als sein dass ausschluss ist nur
möglich dazu da sein gehirn
entschlossenheit gegen befindlichkeit
und verstehen können wie ferne ist die
angst eine ausgezeichnete möglichkeit
wir würden hier das dasein durch sein
eigenes seien keine selbst ein paar das
phänomen logisch das sind die angst
erschlossen ist sein denn als solches in
seinem design bestimmt bzw diese
bestimmung zureichend vorbereitet werden
kann
also es geht hier um die befindlichkeit
befindlichkeit dürfen sie jetzt nicht
verstehen als heute geht es mir nicht so
gut meinte finden ist heute nicht so gut
oder sehr gut sind es geht wirklich im
wörtlichen sinne um das in der welt sein
wo ich mich befinde
befinde wie der im sinne von relationen
in denen ich stehe diese komplexe netz
in relation also wirklich sehr wörtlich
zu verstehen
und da stellte jetzt die angst eine
große rolle spielt er spricht nicht von
emotionen wenn er über angst besten
befindlichkeiten für die analyse der
angst sind wir nicht ganz unvorbereitet
zwar bleibt noch dunkel wie sie unter
logisch mit der furcht dass da man hängt
offensichtlich besteht eine phänomenale
verwandtschaft das anzeichen dafür ist
die tatsache dass bei der phänomene
meist ungeschlagen bleiben und als angst
bezeichnet wird was feucht ist und
furcht genannt wird was den charakter
der angst hat wir versuchen schrittweise
zum phänomen der angst vor zu tun
sie erinnern sich vorhin hatte ich
diesen text vorgelesen von kicker wo er
auch zwischen furcht und angst unter
scheinen gut dasselbe macht jetzt auch
einigen für das verständnis der rede von
der verfallenen flucht daseinsform
selbst muss das jetzt haben wir es in
der welt zahlen
das ist dieses
berühmt berüchtigte wort als
grundverfassung dieses seinen in
erinnerung gebracht werden das wovor der
angst ist dass in der welt sei als zu
welches damit haben sie jetzt eigentlich
die einen der wichtigsten bestimmende
der angst nach heiliger vorliegen also
das objekt könnte man auch sagen die
gegenstand der langst ist nicht eine
spinne oder fliege sowie bei kicker auch
nicht sondern michael gebaut gast
möglichkeit der freiheit und hier ist es
ganz ähnlich das in der welt seien ein
solches wie unterscheidet sich
phänomenal das wovor die angst nicht
ängste von dem wofür die 50 flüchtigen
das wovor er angst ist kein weltliches
sein des daher kann es damit wesen hat
keine wand ist die bedrohung hat nicht
den charakter einer bestimmten
abträglich kein des bedrohten in der
bestimmten hinsicht auf ein besonderes
faktisches sein könnten ist dann so vor
der angst ist völlig unbestritten
diese unbestimmtheit lässt nicht nur
faktisch unentschieden welches in der
weltliche seine droht sein besagt dass
überhaupt das weltliche seien nicht
relevant ist also das wovor ist völlig
unbestimmt und zwar genauso wie die
möglichkeit der freiheit verlieren
bestimmt ist ich kann alles mögliche in
der freien machen muss das aber tun und
da beginnt letztendlich die angst sitzt
in diesem übergang von der möglichkeit
zur wirklichkeit der freiheit nichts von
dem was innerhalb der welt zu handen
oder vorhanden ist fungiert als das
wovor die angst sie ängste also zu
handen damit meint heiliger gegenstände
des gebrauchs zb ein messer das ist
nicht nur vorhanden es liegt da nicht
nur um wie ein stein
der fund ist es ist zu etwas gut kann es
theologisch gefahren aber nicht zu
diesen gegenständen sind mögliche gegen
spielte angst dass in der welt entdeckte
die ländliche deckte wandten des
ganzheit es zu handeln und vorhanden ist
als solche überhaupt ohne männer sind in
sich zusammen die welt die charakter
völliger und bedeutsamkeit in der angst
begegne ich dies oder jenes in dem es
als bedrohlich eine bewandtnis haben
kann also wie schon bei kritiker ist die
angst etwas ziemlich abstrakt es dann
aber auch wieder sehr konkret ist und
das müssen jetzt genau das daher sieht
die angst auch nicht ein bestimmtes hier
und dort aus dem heer sich das
bedrohliche symbolisch müssen auch noch
mehr dass das bedrohliche nirgends ist
charakterisiert das wovor der angst
nirgends sie haben sich an das nichts
der kirche geradezu angst diese weiß
nicht was ist da vor sie sich ängste
nirgends aber bedeutet nicht nichts
sondern da hingegen stand gegen
überhaupt entschlossenheit von welt
überhaupt für das wesenhaft heimlich in
sein dass thronende kann sich deshalb
auch nicht aus einem bestimmten richtung
hält innerhalb der näheren es ist schon
da und doch nirgends es ist so nah dass
es beengt und einem den atem verschlägt
und doch wirkt heiliger streik an einer
stelle auch kommt dass ein bisschen auf
die angst um ihre ideologie zu sprechen
ist hat etwas mit engel zu tun ja den
atem verschlägt beträgt 1
obwohl es doch nirgends ist das ist ja
auch ein bisschen seltsam wie kann
nämlich etwas bedrohen wenn es doch
nirgendwo vor der angst dass nichts ist
es unten drücken
offenbar die aufsässigkeit ist
überwältigt und nirgends besagt
phänomenal dass vor der angst ist die
welt als zeichen die völlige und
bedeutsamkeit die sich ihnen nicht
nirgends bekundet bedeute nicht welt
abwesenheit sind besagt dass das in der
weltliche seien an ihm selbst zu völlig
belanglos ist dass auf dem grunde dieser
unbedeutend
das in einer weltlichen die werden ihre
weltlichkeit sich einzig noch auftreiben
also konkret gesagt angst ist ein
existenzielles phänomen denken sie
zurück an soundtrack nach oben rechts
ist einmal der link zur zum ekel
das ist ganz ähnlich sah trüber als
nachhaltiger aber ich sehe da eine große
parallele vehicle beiseite
letztendlich alles verschwimmt und nicht
mehr konkret die gegenstände zu sehen
sind und die welt als absurd als ganzes
wahrgenommen wird so ist es auch
beleidigen
dass das nicht mehr um etwas konkretes
geht sondern einfach nur noch die
weltlichkeit als solchen nicht mit einer
weltlichen die wirklichkeit lassen
die frage ist ob es die wäre überhaupt
gibt es gibt ein buch das wieder so von
markus grabka titel warum es die welt
nicht gibt
da würde jetzt heutige widersprechen
natürlich gibt es die welt nicht wie ein
ding aber es gibt sie schon so dass sie
bedeutsam ist und zwar gerade in der
hast genau an was noch das wovor er
angst bis die welt also was denkt ist
nicht dieses oder jenes aber auch nicht
vor nicht alles vorhandene zusammen als
summe kein aktives bestehens der welt
sondern die möglichkeit von zu handeln
überhaupt das heißt die welt selbst also
in dieser möglichkeit das muss ich noch
mal hier etwas vorhanden hier
da haben wir natürlich ganz klar ein
bezug zur kündigung
die angst als angst vor der möglichkeit
der freiheit wenn die angst sich gelegt
hatten pflegt die alltägliche rede sagen
es war eigentlich nichts
diese rede trifft in der tat und tisch
das warst war die alltägliche rede geht
auf eine besorgung bewegendes zu handeln
bevor die angst längste ist nichts von
den in der weltlichen zu halten am main
die es nichts von zu handeln dass die
alltägliche umsichtige reden einzig
versteht ist kein totales nichts dass
gründet im ursprünglichsten etwas der
welt diese jedoch gehört unter logisch
lesen haft zu sein des daseins als in
der welt sein wenn sich demnach als das
geworden der angst dass nichts das heißt
die welt als solche herausstellte dann
besagt das wovor die angst sich ängste
ist das in der welt seien selbst gut in
der welt sei es eben wieder diese
möglichkeit der freiheit der welt
erschließen sich mir verschiedene
möglichkeiten aber eben nur dann wenn
ich sie wirklich dass ich ängsten
erschließt überhaupt und direkt die welt
als wild ich gewählt jetzt sofern sie
bestimmte gegenstände helfen die bild
als rahmen dieses mal nicht wird etwa
zunächst durch die belegung von
überwältigt seine abgesehen und nur noch
die welt gedacht vor der dann die angst
entsteht sondern die angst erschließt
als modus der befindlichkeit allererste
welt als nett dies bedeutet jedoch nicht
dass der angst die weltlichkeit der welt
betrifft sind
das könnte jetzt ein bisschen
überspringen
und jetzt war ich noch was wichtiges die
angst offenbart und da sein dass sein
zum eigenen sein können also zu einem
möglichkeiten geht es dem sein schließen
das heißt dass frei sein für die
freiheit des dich wählen und ergreifend
wir haben damit einen ganz klaren bezug
zu kriegen
auch wenn er ihn nicht direkt zitieren
die angst bringt das dasein vor seine
frei sein für die eigentlich kite seines
seins als möglichkeit die es immer schon
ist diese seien aber ist es zugleich
denen das dasein als in der welt seien
über antwortet ist okay also dass da
haben es jetzt in der angst schließen
sich uns die möglichkeiten hier müssen
wir einfach etwas in die hand nehmen und
das macht uns auch angst
so fielen sollen sie jetzt mal gewesen
sein so willkommen heiliger in der
nächsten sitzung geht es dann um das
thema neid und eifersucht auch ein
spannendes thema fallen weil wir hier
dann plötzlich in dem moral
philosophischen kontext com
ich verabschiede mich und freue mich
über diskussion jeder art die gerne
unten dann auf youtube in der kommentar
sektion stattfinden dürfen